[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct dans cinq jours vous allez devoir
choisir et pour vous y aider chaque soir
dans cette émission un grand débat sur
un grand thème de la campagne ce soir
l'urgence climatique nous avons trois
ans pour faire baisser nos émissions co2
pour que la terre reste viable c'est la
lettre de lancer par les scientifiques
du giec dans le dernier volet de leur
rapport les candidats en france
multiplie les propositions pour
décarbonés l'économie alors si à la
trajectoire la plus crédible pour sortir
de nos dépendance au gaz au pétrole et
au charbon va passer au crible les
programmes des candidats dans cette
émission dans un instant notre grand
témoin lui s'est lancé un défi de taille
réconcilier les classes populaires avec
le libéralisme et nous promet même des
trente glorieuses au sortir de la crise
sanitaire mais avec la guerre en ukraine
et l'explosion des prix ce scénario est
il vraiment possible
nous poserons la question à nicolas
bouzou avec nous ce soir enfin duncan à
ce soir jean rémi baudot va nous dire
pourquoi la sphère jérémy qu elle se
fait divers dramatique à bobigny
pourrait perturber cette fin de campagne
montre moi ton meeting je te dirai qui
tu es ce sera avec géraldine muhlmann et
puis l'oeil de blacko bien sûr le carnet
de campagne quotidien si stéphane
blakowski voilà pour le menu ce soir
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs nous avons trois ans
pour tout changer nous alertent le giec
et il nous reste cinq jours seulement
pour faire un choix à la présidentielle
alors on va essayer j'espère de vous et
dès ce soir en s'arrêtant sur les
programmes des candidats pour sauver la
planète à l'heure aussi du retour de la
guerre en europe avec son lot de
conséquences notamment pour le climat
quatre invités sur ce plateau bonsoir
yamina seb on soit revenu vous êtes
membre du giec justement le groupe
d'experts intergouvernemental sur
l'évolution du climat qui vient de
publier ce ce dernier volet de son
rapport vous êtes économiste et
spécialiste des questions énergétiques
bonsoir matthieu auzanneau ravi de vous
retrouver sur ce plateau vous dirigez le
shift project c'est un think tank
d'experts sous la houlette de jean-marc
jancovici qui était sur ce bateau il ya
quelques semaines qui a produit un plan
complet de transformation de l'économie
française c'est est publié chez odile
jacob comment chaque secteur doit
s'adapter pour se mettre en conformité
avec l'accord de paris c'est très très
complet on verra ça et vous avez
également classé si l'on peut dire les
programmes des candidats à l'aune de des
objectifs de l'accord de paris et thomas
bayeto vous vous avez mené aussi ce
travail bonsoir et merci d'être avec
nous est journaliste à france info vous
suivez les questions écologiques france
info dont qui a publié sur son site hier
l'analyse des mesures des candidats
c'est une sorte de classement on le voit
à l'antenne vous allez nous aider à nous
dire comment vous y avez permis va
conduit construit ce classement enfin
dans le fauteuil du grand et mince au
soir nicolas bouzou bonsoir et bienvenue
vous êtes économiste essayiste fondateur
de la société asterès et vous publier ce
livre aux éditions de l'observatoire
pour un libéralisme populaire de mots
qui en général ne vont pas très bien
ensemble et classes populaires elles
libres libéralisme vous allez me dire
que ce que vous mettez derrière ce titre
comment vous comptez les réconcilier ou
si c'est simplement libéralisme qui n'a
pas bonne presse que vous les
populariser on va en parler dans la
deuxième partie de cette émission mais
vous avez plusieurs chapitres consacrés
à l'écologie vous appeler à la
révolution écologique
donc vous êtes forcément très utile à ce
débat je vous donne la parole dans un
instant on va d'abord regarder de plus
près ce que nous dit le giec troisième
volet sa tâche qui s'attache aux
solutions une fois n'est pas coutume on
est moins dans l' alerte sur la
situation que sur les solutions
pratiques à mettre en oeuvre pour
réduire nos émissions c'est un sujet de
malemort
pour limiter le réchauffement climatique
à 1,5 degré celsius l'objectif fixé par
les accords de paris il faut que les
émissions cessent d'augmenter d'ici
trois ans selon le giec
cela impliquerait de se passer presque
exclusivement du charbon comme source
d'énergie d'ici 2050 et de réduire
l'utilisation de pétrole et de gaz
respectivement de 60 et 70% à la
rescousse les énergies renouvelables
selon le giec leurs coûts a
drastiquement baissé depuis 2010 ce qui
facilitera leur déploiement - 85% pour
l'énergie solaire - 55% pour l'éolien
est moins 85% pour les batteries au
lithium maîtres mots du rapport la
sobriété ces petits gestes du quotidien
qui permettent de réduire notre
empreinte carbone préférer le vélo à la
voiture faciliter le télétravail mieux
isoler les bâtiments utiliser le train
plutôt que l'avion des actions qui
pourraient réduire de 40 à 70 % nos
émissions de co2 le giec vise
particulièrement les 10% les plus riches
du monde qui concentrent à eux seuls
entre un tiers et la moitié des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre selon
le giec les financements en faveur du
climat sont encore largement inférieurs
à ceux pour les énergies fossiles pour
limiter à 2 degrés celsius le
réchauffement d'ici 2030 il faudrait
trois à six fois plus d'investissements
qu'aujourd'hui
alors j'ai commencé avec vous il ya
menace à 17 chapitres des milliers de
pages est elle arrivée il ya un
calendrier très serré on a trois ans
pour garder une pierre une planète
viable qu'est ce que ça signifie
concrètement si on faisait plus rien on
passerait un seuil irréversible c'est ça
quand on a trois ans pour agir en fait
la première phrase l'ouverture de la
presse la conférence de presse par le
président de notre groupe était il avait
dit c'est maintenant ou jamais donc si
on veut avoir une planète viable il
faudrait absolument que l'on réduise les
émissions camps fassent le nécessaire
maintenant pour que les émissions
commencent à baisser à partir de 2025
trois ans ça a l'air d'être ça peut ça
peut paraître long mais c'est très très
peu en fait pour mettre en place des
politiques climatiques ambitieuse la
situation elle est plus grave qu'estimé
auparavant malgré la pause mondiale de
la crise sanitaire la pause mondiale de
la crise sanitaire n'a pas conduit à des
changements structurels pour justement
réduire les émissions et d'ailleurs là
on voit maintenant un rebond dans les
émissions une fois que l'économie repart
à peu près comme avant dans la plupart
des pays donc ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
suffisant il faut des changements
structurels et ça on les a pas on va en
parler dans le détail l'objectif de
paris c'était un et demi contenir le
réchauffement un degré et demi ça c'est
déjà hors de portée on est on est tous
sur des scénarios de 2 degrés non le
rapport qui a été publié hier justement
c'est pour rester dans l'objectif de
l'accord de paris c'est entre 1,5 et 2
degrés et ne pas dépasser les 2 degrés
donc si on agit maintenant pourquoi
encore d'oise 2000 25 ans commencent à
baisser c'est encore possible alors il
va falloir des transformations majeures
là on est sur le rapport du giec on
parle de la planète on va venir sur la
france et les propositions des candidats
dans un deuxième temps il ya un autre
enseignement c'est que le coût de
l'inaction faut quand même se réjouir un
peu plus fort et plus grand que le coût
de l'action ça ça veut dire que la prise
de conscience elle est mondiale aussi
bien politiques qu'économiques les chefs
d'entreprise comme le chef d'état ça a
beaucoup progressé
ces dernières années cette compréhension
de l'ampleur du diagnostic on est
confrontés à une évolution qui est
inexorable
qui ce caractère inexorable et de mieux
en mieux perçu compris comme tel
parce que il y a un coût à l'inaction
climatique mais il y a aussi une voiture
balai on le voit avec la crise en
ukraine aujourd'hui
en particulier en europe on pose en
champion du climat on n'en demeure pas
moins aujourd'hui le plus gros
importateur d'hydrocarbures l'union
européenne dans son ensemble a expliqué
sa champion du climat en europe même si
on continue de polluer champions par
l'europe champions championnat et même
les autres championnats parole mais pour
l'instant il suffit de regarder la
circulation par sa fenêtre le matin on
n'a pas commencé à sortir du pétrole et
on voit bien avec vous aimez pas trop
qu'on dise que l'europe fait mieux par
exemple que les états unis ou la chine
j'ai l'impression on est moins mauvais
élève disons mais emmenés non un prix en
fait si vous voulez c'est un c'est un
processus dans lequel il n'y a pas de
demi mesure soit on réussit soit on
échouera et même si on échoue à mi
chemin ou trois quarts de chemin on est
choix et on sera rattrapé par notre
dépendance et ses conséquences
climatiques mais aussi ses conséquences
géopolitiques qu'on voit très clairement
aujourd'hui avec notre dépendance aux
hydrocarbures rien juste pour s'arrêter
encore sur le rapport bon si on regarde
en termes de pollution démission ça
reste les fossiles 1 34% le secteur le
le plus émetteur est ce que c'est
jouable de parvenir et lâche parle de la
planète à réduire de 70%
l'utilisation du gaz mais alors de la
guerre en ukraine en plus ça ça résonne
forcément à 0 charbon dans les trente
ans et à 60 pour cent de pétrole en
moins d'ici 2050 est-ce qu'on a une
petite fenêtre
justement c'est ce que montre le rapport
si elles existent elles existent sauf
que cette fenêtre là un risque de se
refermer si on n'agit pas maintenant si
en 2025 on n'arrive pas à baisser nos
émissions mais la fenêtre existe il faut
la saisir cette opportunité là et ce
rapport-là sert à ça à dire aux
politiques voilà voilà ce qui nous reste
comme comme fenêtre et à vous de là
désir nicolas bouzou on a ce rapport et
à la guerre en ukraine on découvre une
très grosse dépendance européenne au gaz
russe on se rend compte que quand on
veut s'approvisionner autrement il ya
peut-être aussi d'autres solutions
polluantes j'entends parler du gaz de
schiste certains commencent à rouvrir
des centrales à charbon l'allemagne pour
ne pas le nommer est ce que ce contexte
là est un frein ou un accélérateur à
cette lutte pour le climat il ya des
gens qui disent ukraine climat même
combat et les gens qui disent au
contraire ça tombe au plus mal non ça
doit être un accélérateur je vous donne
un exemple très concret moi je fais
partie des gens qui sont promoteurs d'un
boycott de l'union européenne des
hydrocarbures russes à un embargo en bas
y compris le gaz un pas seulement le
pétrole on a des travaux notamment un
travail très intéressant du conseil
d'analysé économique qui a été publiée
juste hier qui montrent que en réalité
cbc mais c'est possible c'est jouable ça
passe pas beaucoup mais c'est possible
mais il s'agit de faire un effort déjà
de sobriété il n'y a pas qu'à sobriété
on peut pas faire que ça pour passer
de s'abriter parce qu'on est tous
derrière de mauvaise brille et et c'est
un changement de comportement vous
donner deux simplement de composer je
vais vous dire donner deux propositions
que j'ai faites dans les médias qui me
font le plaisir de m'ouvrir leurs
antennes ces dernières semaines première
chose limitation de la
vitesse sur les autoroutes de 130 à 110
km heure ça c'est de la sobriété oui oui
2 deuxième chose tous les bâtiments
publics à 19 degrés pour donner
l'exemple on est chauffée en moyenne en
france à 21 degrés ça n'a aucun sens
c'est du gaspillage enfin on a assez
mais même si ça allait pas enfin je veux
dire il faut bien mr que là on a 2 ans
de 4 économique no 10 et avaloirs se
contraindre oui et franchement c'est pas
des contraintes celle ci ne me sens pas
extrêmement méchantes j'ai aussi proposé
je le dis au passage sur dark souls
expertise y est d'ailleurs puisque je ne
suis pas spécialiste mais le passage de
la température dans les piscines
municipales de 29 à 28 degrés à 28
degrés on peut nager matthews anovo a lu
dans l'obs récemment j'ai eu aucun
succès d'ailleurs pardon sobriété en
gros on baise en baisse le chauffage et
y compris dans les piscines la sobriété
c'est notre assurance vie on entend
beaucoup ce mot de sobriété c'est quoi
la sobriété est ce que ces maîtres des
pulls est-ce que c'est rouler à vélo ou
est ce que sait faire une de la
rénovation thermique en s'isolant mieux
il faut comprendre effectivement qu'est
ce qu'on met derrière ce terme là il ya
des mesures de sobriété qui sont
individuelles mettre un pull l'hiver
prochain des solutions qui sont de 2,2
de court terme qui vont avoir un impact
donc dans le contexte de la crise
actuelle si on veut sortir des énergies
fossiles c'est pas seulement une
sobriété des individus c'est une
sobriété de l'organisation sociale c'est
repenser la manière dont se déplace au
quotidien c'est repenser la manière dont
on produit en particulier dont on
produit dans l'agriculture dans
l'industrie et dont on consomme c'est
vraiment réorganiser agir quand le giec
dic c'est la manière de produire c'est
pas moins produire forcément vous voyez
sobriété décroissance parfois en mêlée
la décroissance dans la sobriété où il
ya des activités
croissance des activités qui doivent qui
doivent décroître il y en a des
kilomètres on peut penser par exemple si
on comprend que l'on doit redonner
l'avantagé aux trains dans le
déplacement en europe ça veut dire
chanter les déplacements les vols moyen
courriers par agri mais les vols
intérieurs on va y venir
oui alors justement pour la première
fois le rapport du giec propose une
définition de la sobriété ça s'était
jamais produit auparavant et le terme
sobriété apparaît dans le rapport
malheureusement il apparaît plus
précisément c'est très accentuée dans le
chapitre relatif au bâtiment mais en
fait il ya de la sobriété dans tout ce
qui est réduction de la demande et de le
je voulais je voulais d'abord justement
parce que s'ils disent aubry y était
avec les bâtiments en gros quand on les
plus efficaces est ce que c'est de la
sobriété et en même temps on garde la
même température puisque on fait de la
rénovation thermique ou est-ce qu'il
faut réduire le chauffage voyez la
différence la sobriété et l'efficacité
énergétique sont deux actions complèment
différentes mais complémentaires
nécessaires à la décarbonation et auquel
on doit rajouter
un provisionnement en ressources
renouvelables si vous prenez par exemple
l'exemple du chauffage si vous habitez
vous avez quatre pièces dans votre
appartement en vérité vous n'utilisez
que deux pièces si vous n'avez plus
d'enfants si vous êtes tout seul et à ce
moment là ça ne sert à rien de chauffe
et toutes les pièces de votre
appartement il faudrait chauffer juste
les pièces que vous utilisez ça c'est de
la sobriété sauf que alors on a
l'impression que ça c'est une décision
une décision individuelle mais bien
souvent ce n'est pas une décision
individuelle est justement le rapport du
giec montrent que la sobriété ce n'est
pas juste le changement de comportement
le changement de comportement tout seul
ne va pas se produire sans offrir aux
citoyens les infrastructures nécessaires
pour que ce changement de comportement
se produise on l'a vu avec les pistes
cyclables corona avec le virus les gens
se sont mis à prendre le vélo parce que
maintenant on a la possibilité de le
voir en action ce faire différentes
échelles questions politiques publiques
si les politiques publiques mettent en
place les infrastructures nécessaires
pour que nous ayons des comportements
vertueux ça se produira mais si les
politiques publiques ne font pas ça eh
ben ça ne se produira pas alors on va
regarder le sujet sur les candidats mais
thomas bayeto hier il ya une
illustration incroyable dans nos
quotidiens crt qui nous a demandé très
clairement pour des raisons spécifiques
parce que nos centrales une grande
partie de nos centrales sont à l'arrêt
parce qu'elles sont en train d'être
remise à niveau et donc on a eu ce tweet
baisse des températures rta active le
signal orange concrètement ça veut
baisser le chauffage le matin c'était
quelques heures
évitez les lessives et essayer de faire
en sorte que la facture enfin le
l'utilisation la consommation n'explose
pas parce qu'il y avait cette vague de
froid est ce que vous croyez qu'on va
avoir comme ça et c'est vrai que je
pense que beaucoup de français en
entendant la radio le matin l'on fait
des incitations voire peut-être des
contraintes dans le quotidien dans les
années à venir alors ce qui est sûr
c'est que le réchauffement climatique va
profondément modifier nos modes de vie
dans les années à venir et les décennies
à venir évidemment le monde tel que nous
le connaissons va changer il faudra
qu'on s'y adapte ça c'est clair et net
là c'est l'irruption dans le quotidien
c'est ça c'est nouveau
ça s'est produit dans les années 60 la
crise pétrole a heureusement alors ouais
et juste pour terminer par contre c'est
pas quelque chose qu'on retrouve
beaucoup dans les programmes des
candidats ils sont généralement assez
frileux sur tout ce qui est mesure
sobriété attendait alors on va on va
regarder je vous redonne la parole tout
de suite après thomas thomas bayeto
compter sur moi tour d'horizon des
programmes des candidats pour le climat
c'est un sujet de léo se regarder
quelles technologies pour produire notre
énergie à gauche presque tous les
candidats mission le 100% renouvelable
et la sortie du nucléaire
2032 pour philippe poutou 2045 pour jean
luc mélenchon pas avant 2050 pour anne
hidalgo yannick jadot lui entend arrêté
dix réacteurs en 2035 une exception
fabien roussel je suis le seul à gauche
à dire qu'il faut investir dans la
production d'énergies renouvelables mais
aussi nucléaire les communistes sont
donc en phase avec le reste de
l'échiquier politique
emmanuel macron valérie pécresse marine
le pen eric zemmour nicolas dupont
aignan et jean lassalle sont favorables
au maintien des centrales nucléaires et
à la construction de nouveaux au pm le
nucléaire une énergie que certains
notamment à l'extrême droite voudrait
voir remplacer les éoliennes qui engage
le chantier de des menteurs non des
éoliennes est d'abord la première chose
que je vais faire c'est arrêter les
chantiers qui sont actuellement en cours
l'objectif c'est qu'il y ait pu des
oyats oui moi je dis on arrête l'éolien
on arrêtait un lien sur terre en mer
j'ai vu les pêcheurs de saint brieuc qui
sont catastrophés je veux dire il faut
voir l'éolien est une catastrophe
al'inverse emmanuel macron veut doubler
la production d'énergies renouvelables
d'ici 2030 yannick jadot pour compenser
l'abandon du nucléaire veut lui
construire 3000 nouvelles éoliennes
autre enjeu celui des transports jean
luc mélenchon et yannick jadot veulent
interdire les vols intérieurs lorsqu'il
existe une alternative par le train là
où emmanuel macron veut développer le
premier avion bas carbone pour les
trajets du quotidien tous prônent d'une
alternative à la voiture thermique car
électrique notamment mais divergent sur
la marche à suivre offres de location de
longue durée aides publiques quand
d'autres comme eric zemmour et nicolas
dupont aignan veulent revenir sur les
zones à faibles émissions
pour ne pas pénaliser les plus modestes
je refuse ça c'est clair la fausse
écologie qui culpabilise les français
notamment les automobilistes fabien
roussel promet quant à lui des
transports collectifs gratuits dans les
métropoles
alors thomas payet on va revoir tout de
suite le classement france info avec les
shifter on se rend compte déjà la
première surprise et les programmes par
rapport aux objectifs climatiques de
l'accord de paris c'est que personne ne
remplit la gaze très proche de ses
objectifs comment vous avez construit au
fond ce classement et surprise comment
vous expliquer qu'au fond personne ne
soit au rendez-vous de la bonne note
c'est j'ose dire alors juste avant de
rentrer en détail de ce classement
peut-être rappeler rapidement pourquoi
on a estimé important de le faire
tout à l'heure on a parlé de l'échéance
de 2025 2025 c'est même pas la totalité
du prochain quinquennat et pourtant
c'est un sujet qui a été très absent
dans la campagne les candidats se sont
peu exprimés à ce sujet dans les
émissions politiques on les a peut
interroger aussi une manière un contexte
du coup nous ça nous a paru important
d'insister là dessus et de proposer à
nos lecteurs quelque chose d'un peu
solide et un peu considèrent comment il
est construit au fond
classement une précision d'abord le
alors non on parle pas de classement par
l'évaluation des nappes a été de dire
untel est numéro un tel numéro deux lots
de précisions c'est que c'est que cette
évaluation elle est propre à
franceinfo.fr sur la base bien sûr du
travail de shifter mais je pense que
vous êtes la sasp a souhaité le faire
une telle évaluation et ensuite en fait
on a regardé un petit peu secteur par
secteur
ce que proposait les candidats est
effectivement vous l'avez dit aucun est
tout à fait dans les clous de l'accord
de paris alors bon certains s'en
rapproche alors les les plus proches
c'est surprise parce que yannick jadot
et jean luc mélenchon ont un point
commun c'est que il ne vole pas du
nucléaire tous les deux alors est ce
qu'il faut conclure que c'est une erreur
de vouloir poursuivre le nucléaire pour
être dans les clous comme alors on a été
un petit peu mal habitués en france
parce que le débat sur le réchauffement
climatique il a toujours été très centré
sur la question nucléaire vs énergies
renouvelables alors qu'en fait c'est
bien plus large que ça si on prend les
principaux secteurs émetteurs en france
le premier c'est les transports 31% donc
c'est d'abord une question de comment se
déplacent au quotidien comme on déplace
la marchandise ensuite vous avez
l'agriculture et l'industrie autour de
19% et la production d'énergie dont le
nucléaire c'est aujourd'hui au tour de
10% et que c'était électrique
donc effectivement ça surprendra
peut-être les gens qui sont habitués à
ce qu'on débatte beaucoup de cette
question là mais mais ça ne se limite
pas à ça matthieu auzanneau
pourquoi eux avant les autres parce que
et dont dix ont un programme plus
cohérent et plus complet sur l'ensemble
dès leviers pour réduire les émissions
ils ont plus beau c'est que les autres
et en physique ont fait pas de politique
sur ce plateau on essaye voilà d'aidé
doté des spectateurs à faire des choix
mais hélas aucune consigne de vote les
demis ce soir le le constat le constat
qu'on fait c'est que certaines
organisations politiques ont plus de
pièces du puzzle voilà ils ont travaillé
en sortant dans une pièce du puzzle sur
la mobilité quotidienne en s'inspirant
pas de pas mal de travaux qui sont très
riches en france
on a effectivement avec les
organisations représentent mélenchon et
j'ai a do un travail qui est qui et qui
approfondit sur la décarbonation de
l'industrie il ya un certain nombre
comme ça deux secteurs où les pièces du
puzzle ont été travaillées ce qui manque
est la raison pour laquelle l'analyse
des chiffres donc là l'organisation que
que je côtoie et est donc à utiliser
france info c'est l'assemblage du puzzle
voilà de quoi on parle on parle
d'énergie qu'on logique dit qu'il faut
agir on parle de changer le système
sanguin de la société l'énergie c'est ce
qui apporte
les nutriments enfin c'est ce qui fait
fonctionner c'est exactement comme le
système sanguin donc arriver à sortir
des énergies fossiles en une génération
c'est non seulement le faire une
opération à coeur ouvert mais c'est
changer l'organisation du système qui va
derrière et de tous les organes vitaux
c'est pour ça que je disais tout à
l'heure c'est un problème
organisationnel
comment est-ce qu'on se déplace comment
est-ce qu'on organise les déplacements
comment est-ce qu'on organise par
exemple le système de santé la santé
aujourd'hui c'est 10% pratiquement des
émissions de la france qu'est ce que ça
veut dire un système de santé qui se
passe de pétrole est ce que ça veut dire
juste des ambulances électrique voyez ce
genre de questions qui sont des
questions systémiques parce que le
problème est systémique et le constat
qu'on fait qui est
c'est qu'on a des
progrès dans l'instruction de la
thérapie mais qui est
d'une part un complet et puis à des
refus d'obstacle c'est à dire que dans
toutes les organisations
il ya des problématiques on n'a pas
envie de regarder typiquement est ce
qu'un système électrique 100 %
renouvelable peut tenir la route il ya
un pari qui est extrêmement hardi à mon
avis et au sens du
qui est pas tout à fait celui de rte
c'est à dire que voilà on a une classe
politique il ya une partie de la classe
politique qui a bossé qui a rassemblé un
certain nombre de pièces du puzzle ou ne
voient toujours pas comment est ce qu'on
l'a semble
dans une société qui reste en paix où
l'inflation des coûts l'énergique en
train de vivre ne fait pas exploser le
contrat social etc on est vraiment là et
le dit c'est ce que pointe le giec juste
avant des récifs on est en train de
dériver il faut qu'on trouve une méthode
de navigation qu'on fasse équipage quoi
contre c'est pour ça que c'est un grand
problème
certains ont bossé d'autres non
qu'est-ce qu'elle et révèle ses
programmes de la prise de conscience
alors en regardant les programmes on a
en essayant d'analyser les programmes de
mon point de vue donc j'ai pas regardé
dans le détail ce que l'egypte leur en
fait ce qui m'a tout de suite frappé
c'est que le programme de de mélenchon
et de celui de jadu sont les seuls qui
sont d'abord tiré par la sobriété où il
ya beaucoup de mesures de sobriété dans
les autres programmes on ne trouve pas
ça et on sait que s'il n'y a pas de
sobriété on peut pas décarbonée on va
droit dans le mur et pas très vendeur la
sobriété d'un point de vue électoral
après je ne sais pas ça dépend regardez
la photo des gens qui sont contents que
de monter sur le vélo quand ils peuvent
le faire par exemple c'est vrai il faut
changer le narratif il faut il faut
juste changer le narratif en fait parce
que c'est ce que est ce que vous êtes
plus heureux quand vous passez des
heures dans les bouchons pour aller au
travail pour revenir chez vous que si
vous vous y allez à vélo par exemple
nicolas bosson guerre un chapitre dans
votre livre sur les lignes notamment à
la suppression des lignes intérieures
proposé d'ailleurs par jean luc
mélenchon 1 le chiffre est le et le
shift project il faut ça fait partie
aussi là je sais pas s'il faut utiliser
le mot sobriété mais enfin tout cas la
cdc des choix des choix de politique
industrielle oui absolument la
difficulté de ce sujet c'est qu'il faut
avoir une vision globale alors la vision
des ingénieurs elle est absolument
nécessaire c'est la base il faut partir
de là mais il faut aussi répondre et
résoudre au moins deux autres problèmes
premier problème c'est comment on fait
dans le cadre d'une société d'une
démocratie libérale cirque on va pas aux
glissades d'eau mon point de vue en tout
cas il n'est pas souhaitable sans le
centre doit être le minimum de
contraintes on n'est pas en dictature et
je ne souhaite pas qu'on y aille donc ça
c'est la première chose quand on inscrit
le projet écologique dans cette
démocratie libérale et la deuxième chose
comment est ce que l'on fait pour que le
coût soit absorbable pour les personnes
qui sont les plus modestes c'est un
débat extrêmement concret que l'on a en
ce moment l'ue a par exemple j'ai moi
moi je n'étais pas favorable débat que
j'avais avec le gouvernement mais je
n'étais pas favorable à ce que l'on
baisse la fiscalité sur les carburants
ça a été fait don taxe carbone après
midi les jaunes voilà et maintenant la
baisse là qui vient d'être faite sur le
litre de calais 18 centimes les 15 et 17
exactement mois sur les traverses
pourquoi ce n'étaient pas favorables
parce que j'ai quand même de vieux
réflexes d'économistes quand les prix
augmentent il ya une bonne raison c'est
sensé à changer les comportements c'est
censé permettre la défaut civilisation
de l'économie donc et en même temps je
c'est comme un point de vue d'experts
dire que si j'étais au gouvernement en
charge de ce dossier j'aurais eu à faire
cet arbitrage extrêmement
concret et oui donc enfin ce que je veux
dire en tout cas c'est qu'il faut qu'on
y réfléchisse aussi et qu'on ait des
solutions qui soient pas simplement des
solutions techniques mais qui soit aussi
des solutions sociales sinon ça passera
pas c'est ce que j'explique dans le
livre cirque si l'idée c'est de dire aux
gens vous allez vivre moins bien et
c'est
le capitalisme le capitalisme mieux
régulé c'est une course d'obstacles
plein d'obstacles plein d'obstacles à
cette question tient des sentiments en
moins sur deux litres d'essence
peuvent plus à 10 euros
alors là on est on est confronté
malheureusement parce qu'on n'a pas mis
en oeuvre des politiques consistante il
ya 20 ans on se retrouve dans la main de
monsieur poutine aujourd'hui parce qu'on
n'est pas sorti les énergies fossiles et
parce que également la société n'a pas
eu la consistance et la prévoyance de
développer les alternatives à la bagnole
individuel partout là où c'est possible
et c'est possible jusqu'en grande
banlieue à la campagne c'est plus
compliqué mais là vous n'êtes pas ce que
vous avez fait un plan plus préserve
l'emploi donc la question sociale elle
compte énormément sur dans le temps où
on est parce que c'est toujours un choc
de temporalité les questions climatiques
dans le présent là
écoutez nous donc ça fait 20 ans qu'on
bosse à la décarbonation ondimba vous
faites les pompiers maintenant vous
n'avez pas la société française mais
c'est le valasse est valable pour tous
les pays développés ont signé lebron le
premier engagement climatique a
maintenant 25 ans 1997 kyoto qu'est ce
qu'on a fait depuis
rien ou pas grand chose et bien c'est
pas très agréable dans le rôle de don
dans le rôle de celui qui dit bah on
vous avez bien dit qu'il fallait vous
bougez
situation je rajoute donner un exemple
sur le capitalisme régulé on est
exactement dans la situation d'un toubib
qui dit à quelqu'un qui fume monsieur x
arrêter de fumer est clairement dit
écoutez monsieur je vous l'avais bien
dit la clope moi je suis un ancien
fumeur à la fin des années 90 quand on
disait faut arrêter de fumer on va
interdire de fumer dans les restaurants
tofu et puissent puis s'est passé est
passé symboliquement on a une salle 1
raisonnement salubre affaires et ce
raisonnement il est profond ils et
organisationnel il est politique et la
démonstration qu'on fait avec les
alternatives à la voiture individuelle
c'est que vous pouvez permettre en
investissant pendant une dizaine
d'années alors évidemment ce n'est pas
une réponse immédiate évidemment pas ce
qu'il aurait fallu faire ces
investissements il ya dix ans et les
écolos sérieux bien sûr mais
avec les démocraties ya une échéance
électorale quand on regarde maman mes
versions de travail étant sous le mot
valable et qui permettent également de
aux gens de réduire leur budget mobilité
de réduire
le bas du classement quand même pas ce
qu'il en dit long aussi sur ce décalage
entre l'urgence que vous décrivez la
révolution systémique est que vous
appelez et les plus mauvais alors classé
évalué il ya encore beaucoup de
candidats qui sont pour
supprimer toutes les éoliennes d'autres
considèrent que l'écologie au fond elle
est plus punitives que positive il ya et
vous avez décortiquer tous les
programmes qu'est-ce qu'on pouvait nous
dire sur ce qu'ils sont très loin des
objectifs de paris alors effectivement
pour tout un tas de candidats le
réchauffement climatique c'est plus pas
du tout un sujet ça les préoccupent pas
ça les empêche pas de dormir et c'est
pas très présent dans leur programme
et ils ont tort parce que vous donniez à
l'instant le mode écologie punitive
mais l'écologie punitive la vraie on la
voit quand il ya des catastrophes
qu'elles naturel du réchauffement
climatique et on le voit bien sûr dans
les pays du sud qui sont le plus
durement frappé mais on le voit aussi
chez nous on peut parler de la rouille a
récemment peu parlé ce qui s'est passé
en belgique en allemagne donc il ya
matthieu auzanneau parler de refus
d'obstacle
il ya un peu sachez chez ses grand bruit
puis pour des gens qui sont des
patriotes il ya un refus de respecter la
parole nationale les accords de paris
ont été signés à paris les accords de
paris c'est une ordonnance celle
ordonnance du toubib alors on peut dire
je m'en fiche je continue je continue à
fumer mais on peut pas dire après nous
le déluge c'est pas possible enfin en
tout cas moi je peux pas me résoudre à
dire ça je voudrais qu'on termine ce
débat en changez un tout petit peu
d'échelle parce que rien ne sera
possible on le comprend bien si on
n'agit pas au niveau européen et au
niveau de la planète il ya sur la table
alors la guerre en ukraine un peu
suspendue cette un jardin européenne
mais la taxe carbone aux frontières de
l'europe est ce que c'est le bon moment
pour la faire est ce que c'est le bon
timing pour la faire est-ce que celle
arme absolue il faut continuer ou on se
rend compte que la taxe carbone avec le
prix du gaz et du pétrole qui explose ça
va être compliqué alors elle a besoin
c'est pas c'est pas l'armé absolue mais
il faut absolument la faire et la
réponse des économistes en règle
générale est de dire la taxe carbone
elle doit être intégralement
redistribuées pour aider justement les
gens qui par exemple n'ont pas les
moyens d'acheter une voiture électrique
d'acheter ou de changer de passer au
pompage à l'heure où je ne sais quoi il
faut les aider d'accord mais bon comme
vous avez des pénuries de matières
premières donc si vous mettez en place
une taxe est secouriste ça change rien
ça n'accroît pas la pénurie 1 ce qui
accroît la pénurie je pars politisés
mais c'est le ce que proposent certains
le blocage des prix ça ça fait des
pénuries mais si vous faites une taxe
carbone ça fait pas de bénéfices est
censé aider à changer les comportements
donc c'est absolument nécessaire et mon
pari c'est que bon l'europe va le faire
mais si l'europe le fait de toute façon
la chine d'autres continents comme une
sorte on aurait parié rétorsion mais qui
sera assez vertueux au niveau mondial
pour lequel il faut que le rapporte ça
et qu'elle le fasse mais vraiment que
l'intégralité soit redistribuée est ce
que c'est ça qui avait dysfonctionné au
moment des filets jaunes yamina faible
taxe carbone aux frontières de l'europe
pour toutes les importations je pense
qu'il faut pas retenir bonne quand on
apporte je pense qu'il faut pas garder
uniquement la taxe carbone il faut
regarder l'ensemble du paquet énergie
climat dit fit fortyfive que la
commission européenne a proposé pour
agresser la mise en oeuvre du green deal
européen donc on a un paquet énergie
climat il ya plein de plein
d'instruments dedans et qui a pour
objectif point de vue parole d'aligner
l'union européenne les objectifs
climatiques de l'union européenne avec
l'accord de paris mais dans la pratique
lorsque vous faites le calcul les chiens
n'y sont pas et en plus donc on nous
parle d'une transition juste dans le
cadre du green deal et les instruments
proposés ne vont pas conduire à une
transition juste ils vanteront
reconduire moi je n'arrête pas de le
dire à bruxelles à a créé un mouvement
gilet jaune européen
ça risque de s'embraser je veux pas
confondre low key le plan de montage il
ya un problème d'adaptation aux fêtes de
l'outil ça va trop vite et trop fort
c'est sa part dont les parce qu'il ya
plein de gars plein de choses dans ces
outils du green deal par exemple sur le
volet agricole on nous dit que les
jachères qui doit faire respirer un peu
les terres ça s'était imposé par la
politique agricole commune on va devoir
produire plus donc on s'assoit sur ces
jachères et on va les agriculteurs vont
pouvoir les réutiliser on a l'impression
là encore que voilà ce choc des
temporalités l'urgence commande
peut-être de mettre entre parenthèses
ses objectifs étant non pour moi le gros
problème qu'il ya avec le fifty fifty
five c'est que c'est assez ses pensées
avec les instruments du passé et c'est
un paquet néolibérale
d'avion et transition depuis conditions
effet dans le cadre du néolibéralisme je
suis désolé et donc du coup quand on a
là
quand on a une proposition par exemple
d'étendre
un instrument carbonneau
au logement et aux transports engagement
et autres ça va donner quoi ça va donner
une augmentant la crise déjà donc ça va
donner une augmentation des factures
énergétiques
pour qui pour les plus démunis ce sont
eux qui vont être touchés qu'il est mal
calibré mal séché pour témoigner des
outils et le plan de montage
transition toute trouvée voilà il faut
comprendre qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'on
fait de cet argent et quelques qu'est ce
qu'on demande à l'économie
comment est-ce qu'on veut réorganiser un
certain nombre de fonctions vitales la
société se déplacer manger et c est
juste peut-être pour finir chaque
énergie climat de l'union européenne il
n'y a pas une seule mesure de sobriété
dans le paquet énergie climat de l'union
rien dans qu'il est complètement à
revoir vu la parole rapport du giec
publié hier bon ben voilà c'est dit le
chantier est ouvert en attendant
j'espère que vous voyez un peu plus
clair sur cette question climatique dans
les programmes merci beaucoup vous
rester avec moi nicolas bouzou parce que
justement transition toute trouvée le
libéralisme et l'écologie de libéralisme
peut-il être populaire vous l'avez ce
titre pour un libéralisme populaire
position de l'observateur on va en
parler c'est une contribution au débat
présidentiel pour que la france
redevienne une grande puissance mais au
service des plus fragiles vous insistez
sur cela dans votre livre alors comment
précisément avant de vous donner la
parole on voit cela avec thibaut enoch
merci on vous invite nicolas bouzou
c'est que vous nous promettez des
lendemains qui chantent de nouvelles
trente glorieuses sont possibles dites
vous après les crises que nous
traversons
forcément en ces temps où l'inflation
s'envole et où nos portefeuilles
souffrent cela nous intéresse
bien sûr il y à une condition il
faudrait qu'ils vous écoutent nos
candidats à la présidentielle votre
recette est simple le libéralisme tous
azimuts pourtant rien à faire il y en a
qui font la sourde oreille je pense
qu'il faut la renverser cette société
capitaliste parce qu'elle ne peut
fonctionner bien que pour les riches
parce qu'elle est fondée sur
l'exploitation parce que c'est sa nature
même sa nature même fait qu' il y en est
pour les profits l'économie capitaliste
et est incapable de subvenir aux besoins
des populations elle vit de crise en
crise et qu aucun talent apporte des
réponses à la crise elle aggrave sa
propre crise vous le voyez nicolas
bouzou il y encore du travail vous qui
êtes économiste essayiste et chroniqueur
fondateur d'une société de conseil
n'avait pourtant de cesse de les
défendre les vertus du libéralisme dans
vos ouvrages le dernier affirme même
qu'il serait populaire puisque je
rappelle dans le livre c'est que le
libéralisme depuis le 19e siècle a
toujours eu en france le souci de la
défense des plus petits des plus
fragiles et tous les libéraux ont
toujours été du côté des petits n'écrit
de tocqueville sur la pauvreté est
absolument fascinant c'est vrai qu'avec
vous le libéralisme a réponse à tout le
défi écologique la croissance et
l'innovation nous sauverons la fracture
sociale il faut travailler plus pour
riise les plus
proposait même de passer au stade de
l'inondation en distribuant des actions
gratuites à tous les salariés d'ailleurs
le problème pour vous ce sont les
barrages les blocages il faut des
réguler davantage
débureaucratiser et diminuer toujours et
encore la dépense publique seulement
cette recette est elle toujours la bonne
nicolas bouzou en 2014 vous affirmez
ainsi que d'ici 10 ans nous aurions deux
fois trop de lits d'hôpitaux on ne peut
pas dire que le cobp il vous est donné
raison alors le libéralisme est il la
solution miracle à tous les problèmes
n'est-il vraiment pour rien dans les
désastres du temps présent ou rendre at
il réellement tous plus riches à
l'avenir éclairez nous nicolas bouzou au
fond vous savez on a vraiment envie d'y
croire
voilà beaucoup de questions vous allez y
répondre peut-être déjà qu'est ce que
vous mettez dans cette expression
libéralisme populaire est ce que on peut
le rendre vraiment plus profitable aux
plus pauvres aux plus modestes sur en
fait j'ai voulu prendre le contre-pied
d'une expression qui a d'ailleurs été
employées lors du débat précédent qui
est celle de néolibéralisme en fait le
néo libéralisme n'a pas grand chose à
voir avec le libéralisme le nez aux
libyens le néolibéralisme c'est une même
du mal elle dire quasiment une idéologie
révision économistes et même financière
du libé a dû du libéralisme mais qui est
une sorte d'austérité qui visent à tous
diminué le libéralisme dans la tradition
française notamment du xixème siècle
c'est pas ça et en fait le libéralisme
en france a toujours été populaire les
grands libéraux 19e siècle ont souvent
sylvia gauche un taux de ville assiégée
à gauche bastia siéger à gauche et ils
ont systématiquement été à l'origine des
grandes lois sociales grand bastia sur
la liberté de faire la grève par exemple
quand bastien parlementaire explique que
les salariés doivent avoir le droit de
faire la grève la liberté vous parlez
beaucoup est ce que pour vous le mot
libéralisme ou leur envoyer davantage à
une notion politique plus qu'économique
seulement pour moi c'est une notion
philosophique
avant d'être une notion est comme hiver
les inventions en fait en fait partie
mais vous voyez par exemple ces
dernières années moi j'ai notamment
soutenu l'ouverture
la pma aux couples de femmes parce que
j'ai considéré que c'était très
important dans une société comme la
nôtre de proposer cette liberté nouvelle
que des phares disons le que des femmes
homosexuelles puissent enfanté strict
c'était un progrès très importants une
liberté nouvelle loyers et donc là on
n'est pas du tout dans le champ
économique
économique il existe sur suis très
attaché vous y est très attaché ce que
vous pensez que certes la mondialisation
la libéralisation des échanges certains
réduit les inégalités dans le monde les
plus pauvres en chine dans certains pays
émergents comme singapour le savent bien
oui mais elle a quand même c'était
perdant en france vous avez réseau tam
ans dans les pays industrialisés
européens en particulier
vous avez tout à fait raison c'est la
raison pour laquelle je pense qu'il faut
mener une politique libérale sociale qui
devrait d'ailleurs l'agenda d'un
prochain quinquennat je vous donner
quelques exemples les questions
d'éducation et de formation faut
absolument mais mettre beaucoup plus
l'accent sur ces sujets quand je vois la
dégradation de la qualité du niveau en
mathématiques par exemple en france je
suis vraiment très inquiet ans entrée en
matière de santé l'état doit être de
retour si vous disiez blanc même il ya
quelques années avant la crise n et r
trop de lits nos cerveaux attend les
yeux justement je me permets de
l'autoriser pour répondre à ça déjà j'ai
toujours soutenu une augmentation des
dépenses de santé plus importante que ce
qui était fait en france toujours rire
donc on peut se référer c'est très
facile à tout ce que j'ai écrit sur ce
sujet sur la question des lits
d'hôpitaux contrairement à ce qui a été
dit dans votre reportage non je n'avais
pas tort on ne juge pas la qualité d'un
système de santé au nombre de lits au
délit je peux aller vous en achetez et
on peut en mettre absolument partout en
réalité avec soin
en fait pourquoi est ce que j'avais fait
ce tweet qui m'a valu tout un tas de de
menacer de problèmes comme si d'ailleurs
les débats intellectuels devait se faire
sur sur twitter mais pourquoi parce que
en réalité il ya une révolution
technologique qu'on appelle
l'ambulatoire qui permet à des gens
d'être hospitalisée de plus en plus chez
eux ou de ne pas dormir à l'hôpital la
nuit c'est fait c'est ce que demandent
nos concitoyens
je le mets en rapport d'ailleurs avec le
scandale orpea les gens qui sont en
situation de dépendance ils préfèrent
être chez eux la sphère plutôt qu'en
établissement donc voilà sur ce twitt je
pense qu' il faudra quand même fermé la
page alors j'aimerais qu'on revienne aux
livres ce livre il a été écrit avant la
guerre en ukraine
vous écrivez c'est votre première chaîne
le chapitre qu'on pourrait s'attendre au
fond d'un mâle sort toujours un bien un
sursaut les trente glorieuses c'est
votre titre après après 7,7 crise bon
c'était avant la guerre c'était avant l
explosion des prix on est dans un
contexte d'inflation importants né à 4
4% en france en allemagne c'est ses 7 %
se ruent dans les supermarchés plus de
40 % d'augmentation sur la farine par
exemple on n'en prend pas du tout chemin
à la des trente glorieuses bon on va
voir on a pu états unis on est quasiment
à 10 % d'inflation alors les trente
glorieuses en france en l'occurrence il
y avait de la croissance et de
l'inflation mais fondamentalement on est
aujourd'hui au coeur d'une nouvelle
révolution industrielle c'est celle du
numérique de l'intelligence artificielle
des robots des biotechnologies aussi on
l'a vu pendant la crise des imprimantes
3d bon bref y'a plein de choses toutes
ces technologies convergent et elles
nous permettent de proposer des produits
qui sont tout à fait nouveau et qui
offre des solutions qui sont nouvelles
par exemple dans le domaine de la santé
dans le domaine de l'industrie dans le
domaine de l'accès à la culture ça c'est
un vecteur de croissance qui est très
important
cette guerre elle va nécessiter
par exemple une augmentation des
dépenses militaires importantes on va
avoir des applications de ces
innovations dans le domaine militaire
cette guerre personne ne pouvait la
souhaitait bien évidemment mais en
économie vous avez une espèce de loi
historique
nécessité fait loi si vous voulez et
donc je pense que cette croissance elle
est possible de la même façon que la
crise qu vide a permis de débloquer un
certain nombre de choses en matière
d'innovation en santé par exemple tout
ce qui se faisait dans le domaine de la
rn message et on pourra avoir le même
phénomène en raison de la mer' garder on
en parle et
15 secondes en a parlé lors du débat
précédant cette guerre elle doit nous
obliger de mon point de vue à accélérer
la sortie des énergies fossiles mais il
ya une chose dans le contexte les vous
êtes économiste quand on vous les pré
montées comme ça si les salaires aussi
augmentent le risque c'est la stagnation
la fameuse menace du choc pétrolier
c'est ce qui nous guette ou pas moi je
dis moi je pense que c'est peut-être
spirale parce que c'est un gros risque
je fais plutôt par un mythe je fais
partie de ceux qui sont plutôt
pessimistes
du point de vue de l'inflation si vous
voulez un expliquez-nous ce qui peut se
passer en fait on a aujourd'hui des
augmentations de prix qui viennent d'un
peu partout cercle ya l'énergie bien
évidemment mais il ya aussi
l'alimentation qui est plus
problématique que l'énergie en réalité
parce que si vous prenez les céréales
30% des exportations de céréales dans le
monde c'était sur la mer noire donc ça
ça va pas se remettre en place tout de
suite ils voulaient donc là on va avoir
des augmentations de prix qui sont
importantes il y en avait déjà avant la
crise en raison de la crise qu vide mais
qui sont toujours dont les ressorts sont
toujours présents aujourd'hui il
faudrait vous rappeler qu'au moment où
on se parle shanghai 25 millions
d'habitants est confiné de façon plus
stricte que nous l'étions nous il ya
deux ans donc du point de vue économique
de la production ça pose d'énormes
problèmes donc il ya des des
restrictions d'offres et des
augmentations de prix si vous voulez un
peu partout mais une chute de la
croissance avec une augmentation des
prix et des salaires que c'est possible
ce scénario la gueule oui c'est possible
la question c'est dans quelle mesure est
ce qu'on peut avoir une augmentation des
salaires alors l'augmentation des
salaires elle est bonne en soi bien
évidemment mais si vous avez une
augmentation des salaires qui est très
supérieur à ce que peuvent se permettre
les entreprises là vous entrez pardonnez
moi d'être un tout petit peu technique
dans ce qu'on appelle la spirale prix
salaires c'est-à-dire une inflation qui
devient auto entretenue et et qui ne
profite à personne c'est la raison pour
laquelle je parlais de politique sociale
il faut aider aujourd'hui on le fait
beaucoup en france 1 mais il faut
continuer d'aider ceux qui ont des
difficultés donc chèque énergie on l'a
fait cheikh alimentation je suis
favorable voyez ce que je veux dire par
là qu'il nous reste très peu de temps
j'aimerais qu'on aime on accueille nos
chroniqueurs pour le scan vous croyez
énormément aux progrès technologiques et
voilà ce progresse c'est la source de
croissance de l'avenir et qu'est ce que
vous faites parce que ce sera forcément
des emplois très qualifiés
l'intelligence artificielle la robotique
vous parliez des biotechnologies qu'est
ce que vous faites au fond de tous les
emplois non qualifiés qui risquent de
rester sur le carreau pourquoi vous ne
défendez pas le revenu ni versé alors un
nom mais le revenu universel
demande d'accompagner la transition le
revenu universel est attendu pour tout
le monde je vous le dis très gentiment
je ne veux pas que vous l'ayez je ne
veux pas la voir et je ne veux pas que
mes enfants lait non une société comme
la france elle donne plus à ceux qui ont
moins donc pas de revenu universel ces
personnes là je les forme davantage je
les aide davantage puis je veux dire
on est déjà en pénurie d'emplois il ya
quelques années on me disait ce sera la
fin du travail avec ces technologies
c'est très exactement la version n'a
jamais eu autant besoin on n'avait
jamais eu besoin d'autant de monde donc
c'est une chance d'intégration en france
mais on se débrouille plutôt bien mais
c'est pour ça que la question de
l'éducation de la formation elle
absolument
libéralisme en tout cas on peut faire en
sorte que tout le monde y trouve son
compte puis il faut obtenir aussi un peu
ce type de discours par rapport aux
zones là qui arrive de la fédé bien afin
d'optimiser j'espère mais le pire le
pire c'est que je crois que j'ai raison
bon on va écouter en tout cas je vous
invite à lire ce livre pour un
libéralisme populaire nicolas bouzou
faut rester avec moi on va continuer à
ausculter cette campagne présidentielle
avec nos chroniqueurs ça s'appelle le
scan j - 5 déjà avant le premier tour
mais avant d'être il y a les deux pas de
fatalité au grand remplacement et bien
molle vous propose le round mort d'agir
pour le climat l'assimilation
la république c'est moi la prendre
orange ma chronique
travailleuses et travailleurs le système
bose exclu il ya un vrai problème de
pouvoir d'achat rendre à la france sa
grandeur caritas a pas de mystère c'est
le vol
3 scanner trois chroniqueurs sur ce
plateau stéphane blakowski comme tous
les soirs pour son carnet de campagne
bonsoir tu es fan made in human
politologue qui va nous parler des
meetings et de certains grands absents
des invités mystère on est on en parle
tout à l'heure et puis avec vous jean
rémi baudot bonsoir on va revenir sur ce
fait divers absolument dramatique à
bobigny ce qu'on appelle désormais la
sphère jérémy cohen on commence par par
votre carnet de campagne pas votre
carnet de campagne qu'est ce qui attire
et votre oeil ce soir ce soir ce sont
les tpb c est quoi les tout petits
petits candidats les tpp fait tout
simplement fait il ya deux candidats qui
n'ont jamais franchi haute et au-delà
d'1 % c'est artaud et pout tout mais
vous savez que depuis maintenant 15
jours enfin une semaine puisqu'il va y
avoir 15 jours où les temps de parole
sera absolument égal entre les candidats
donc on se dit puisque maintenant il
parle autant que les autres est ce que
il en tire bénéfice dans les sondages
c'est parce qu'on ne les entendait pas
alors qu'est ce que c'est de là bas non
non non non ça ne change pas grand chose
si on prend par exemple nathalie arthaud
elle est passée sur tous les grands
médias et pourtant elle est toujours
dans cette oscillation entre 0 5 et 1%
pourtant à la ferme des propositions qui
pourraient séduire monde et les classes
populaires puisque par exemple je
propose de mettre le smic à 2000 euros
net alors qu'il est aujourd'hui à 1270
euros m noyés quand même deux millions
de français payés au smic ouais pour
elle et je n'ai que c'est quand même une
proposition qui les intéressent eh ben
non ils français qui sont mal payés ne
veulent pas être mieux payés ils ne
veulent pas voter pour
c'est pour ça vous pensez de 1000 euros
nets directement comme ça mais si cela
peut expliquer un peu séisme un peu plus
ambitieux que les dix petits pourcents
propose mélenchon ça c'est vraiment une
vraie augmentation si on le met à 2000
euros net du smic c'est 60 %
d'augmentation oui la changer la vie qui
est un truc de gauche et dans la vie
elle change vraiment oui c'est peut-être
un peu beaucoup 60% n'est pas pour qui
un mois ce que je vous dis c'est que le
minimum toute façon c'est 35 %
d'augmentation du smic et n'allez pas
dire à nathalie arthaud que ce n'est pas
possible parce qu'on l'a déjà fait on
les écoute vous savez en mai 68 c'était
exactement la même musique avec vous
revendication vous allez mettre par
terre toute l'économie mai 68 ça a été
une grève générale une grève générale
qui a conduit à 35% entre 5 35 %
d'augmentation du smic et ça n'a pas mis
les petites entreprises par terre ce
n'est pas vrai voilà alors sécurité en
revanche allait elle est moins peut-être
crédible sur la russie nathalie arthaud
alors disons qu'elle a le mérite de la
franchise
contrairement à mélenchon le pen et
moore qui est ont retourné leur veste
précipitamment en dix ans mais
aujourd'hui on n'a pas exactement 10 à
elle elle continue de dire non moi je
pense que par rapport à ce qui se passe
en russie l'otan est vraie
responsabilité dans le déclenchement du
conflit un peu difficile de la suivre là
dessus pas même well as l'occident
impérialiste voilà où elle peut
peut-être peut-être réfléchir à défaut
de lui donner raison c'est quand elle
dit attention il ya peut-être d'autres
criminels ceux qui par exemple spéculent
sur les cours du blé en écoute moi
j'accuse tous ces spéculateurs là en col
blanc un duo de leur bourse de leur
marché de chicago de londres 2 ils sont
pas moscou 1 1 mais moi je me dis que ce
sont aussi des criminels des crimes et
parce qu'ils savent parfaitement qu'en
faisant flamber le cours du blé bon
affamés des centaines de millions de
femmes et d'hommes voilà en attendant
elle plafonne toujours un pour cent
c'est ça mais les sondages bref
exactement un constat qu'on peut faire
malgré le fait qu'elles passent autant
que les autres désormais elle n'avançait
important je ne sais pas si vous vous
souvenez mais lutte ouvrière qui est
donc le parti d'un atelier retouille
dépassé les 5% arlette laguiller a fait
deux fois au-dessus de 5% en 95 et en
2002 et ça va pas mieux pour le npa même
pea qui est le nouveau parti
anticapitaliste il avait besancenot
besancenot en 2002 plus de 4% en 2007 +2
4% ça veut dire qu'en 2002 en france si
on ajoute laguiller et besancenot
s'était 5 et 4 on était presque 10%
français qui ont voté pour un candidat
trop de points et on l'a oublié mais
c'est vrai sauf qu'aujourd'hui le but
she came la castille ce n'est plus ce
que c'était c'est même complètement
dépassé et donc forcément pour nous tous
il ya un léger léger léger vague à l'âme
on écoute bon je vous parle pas des
sondages parce que
c'est c'est démoralisant des fois aux if
i télé on est toujours un fin c'est
portes et pourtant on fait beaucoup de
choses pour la
je vois pas pourquoi vous applaudissez
c'est en fait c'est un peu vexant quand
même elle a un côté stand-up show man
reste sympathique pas tout espérer
peut-être dépassé année l'album oui ça
c'est ce que disent les journalistes
présents dans l'hôtel mort album chez
pout tout ça va pas si mal vous allez
peut-être faire mieux que le ps quand
même c'est rigolo cette histoire alors
lui ça le fait pas du tout rire cette
histoire en revanche que philippe poutou
c'est le symbole de l'échec de la gauche
et de la destruction de la gauche parce
qu'en fait il ya 20 ans nous dirait
combattre et le ps son oreille ou la
sarre signifier qu'on aurait été au zoo
dans les scores ce qui est pas du tout
le cas en fait on est dans les mêmes
scores sauf qu'on a sauf que c'est le ps
qui s'effondre donc pas de ce point de
vue là il peut y avoir la petite
satisfaction pour nous de passer au
dessus du ps mais mais la satisfaction
c'est que la gauche est cool et qu'on a
plus de gauche est donc assez lucide
malgré tout sur la situation de la
gauche à cette élection en revanche
chaîne hidalgo ont fait 2 % mais on est
toujours à fond on y croit bien sûr
qu'on va gagner en écoute
[Applaudissements]
construire la nation de nos rêves
ensemble nous pouvons changer d'avis
alors vive la république
elle est maman
et bible après
les remarques je trouve que elle est
remarquablement courageuse elle défend
des choses je trouve que voilà tout le
monde se moque des
candidats mais j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration pour elle alors on va
parler d'un tout autre sujet avec vous
jean rémy ça peut devenir un fait
compagnon va voir comment les choses
évoluent vous allez revenir ce soir sur
un terrible drame qui s'est invitée dans
la campagne présidentielle la mort d'un
jeune homme juif il s'appelle il
s'appelait jérémy cohen un petit rappel
des faits 16 février dernier à bobigny
jérémy cohen 31 ans est violemment
agressé par une dizaine de personnes
alors qu'il traverse la rue pour fuir
ses agresseurs il est brutalement
percutées par un tramway y perdra la vie
un peu plus tard à l'hôpital voilà les
faits tels qu'on les connaît aujourd'hui
car au départ les premières
constatations de la police font état
d'un banal tragique accident de la
circulation en fait c'est grâce à
l'exploitation de la vidéo tournée par
un riverain qu'on sait désormais qu'il a
été brutalisé avant le drame néanmoins
ce que la vidéo ne dit pas c'est ce qui
s'est passé avant et d'un mobile de
l'agression est devenu un sujet
politique oui avec une question cette
agression avait-elle un caractère
antisémite lors d'une conférence de
presse aujourd'hui le procureur de
bobigny précise pour l'instant et il le
dit bien pour l'instant n'avoir aucun
élément pour accréditer accréditer cette
hypothèse en attendant d'en savoir plus
néanmoins tous les candidats à la
présidentielle ont réagi mais c'est bien
eric zemmour qui pousse le plus le sujet
il avait en fait été directement
sollicités par la famille de la victime
qui lui avait demandé de l'aide il a
aussi reçu le père aujourd'hui et depuis
deux jours et bien il multiplie les
tweets notamment celui là est il mort
pour fuir les racailles est il mort
parce que juif pourquoi cette affaire
était tout fait il en a parlé aussi sur
tf1 hier soir ils dénoncent une omerta
politiques et médiatiques marine le pen
aussi s'est emparée de cette affaire oui
marine le pen qui laisse entendre que
certains auraient intérêt à cacher la
vérité écoutez la est-ce qu'on n'a pas
en réalité
travesti 7 cet acte affreux qui a
consisté à frapper a molesté un jeune
juif handicapés qui du coup s'est enfui
et est mort en fait de cette fuite
éperdue
parce que on ne voulait pas parler de
cela au moment de la campagne
présidentielle que vous voyez vous vous
pensez que ça a été cachée c'est çà
s'est quand même penser que c'est pas un
accident moi je me pose la question de
savoir si il faut pas une enquête
parlementaire alors qui peut imaginer
que les médias aient eu connaissance de
la totalité de l'histoire depuis six
semaines et qu'il n'y a pas eu un seul
papier à la demande de qui dans quel but
pour cacher la réalité la cruauté de
l'antisémitisme en france aujourd'hui
évidemment les deux leaders d'extrême
droite n'apporte aucune réponse il joue
avec l'émotion pire ils sèment le doute
avant les conclusions de l'enquêté en
laissant entendre que la justice serait
aux ordres pourrait tout fait
politiquement la vérité c'est ce qu'on
appelle du pur populisme et d'autres
affaires qui s'était invité à tout toute
fin de la campagne save est retourné de
oui souvenez vous il ya pile 20 ans la
sphère papy voise 2002 ce retraité
d'orléans qui avait été agressé chez lui
voler roué de coups sa maison a été
brûlée c'était trois jours avant
l'élection beaucoup considèrent que
cette affaire avait nourri un sentiment
d'insécurité et poussé jean marie le pen
au second tour alors est ce que cette
affaire peut avoir la même résonance
aujourd'hui l'avocat de la famille cohen
dénonce par avance les récupérations
mais le sujet est désormais bien au
coeur du jeu politique avec quelques
mots clés banlieue racaille
antisémitisme et règlements lui il sait
très bien ce qu'il fait en agitant tous
ces sujets
il a
été reçu par le par le président
il a eu le cabinet au téléphone que ces
cabinets au téléphone on va terminer
avec géraldine avec un sujet plus léger
vous avez regardé au fond la gestuelle
et rhétorique des différents candidats
il ya parfois des procédés utilisés pour
susciter l'émotion dans les meetings
wheeler y en a un qui est très classique
c'est d'invoquer un absent ou une
absente qui de ce fait devient un peu
présents ou présente et cela suscite
évidemment une énorme émotion qui peut
être positive ou négative à l'ordre dans
la campagne regardez par exemple la
version la plus classique de ce procès
procédé rhétorique avec anne hidalgo le
12 décembre à perpignan
cette affaire
qui chante au vent d'espagne avec cet
accent qui est celui de la liberté
je le vous dis je vous le dis avec toute
mon âme non pasaran aïe aïe aïe
avec l'accent impeccable évidemment et
cette formule on la doit à une femme
communiste appelé la pasionaria de la
guerre d'espagne dolores ibarruri qui
était toujours vêtu de noir le visage
pâle très engagé bien sûr contre les
fascistes de franco c'est une icône
parfaite pour la gauche en campagne
contre zemmour et le rassemblement
national alors il arrive aussi qu'on
évoque d'autres personnages un peu moins
iconique - meetic oui pas besoin de
mythes on peut très bien faire référence
à un absent pour susciter une forte
émotion mais même un absent pour
susciter des émotions au style et ça
peut très bien marcher regarder comment
marine le pen convoque macron macron
jupiter nommés uniquement de cette façon
le 5 mars lors du lors du meeting
d'aigues mortes alors à nous de ramener
jupiter dans le réel dans la réalité
française c'est à dire dans ce que
vivent les français
à quatre semaines de l'élection il a
daigné de l'olympe
envoyé un message à la terre
sous forme d'une lettre à la presse
régionale
marchand est ce que ça marche justement
ça marche ça marche
mais c'est payant ou pas ses classiques
alors c'est payant quand c'est bien
préparé là ça marche très bien mais il
peut y avoir a loupé de temps en temps
et on en a eu un très bon exemple
dimanche dernier au meeting de valérie
pécresse à paris quant à
[Musique]
donner ce n'était pas elle justement
c'était sans doute de ce point de vue là
mal préparée c'était yann wehrling qui
est un écologiste soutenant la candidate
qui s'exprimait je suis sûr que vous
reconnaîtrez l'extrait nicolas sarkozy
[Musique]
je ne voulais pas je ne voulais
absolument pas cette réaction bien au
contraire vous devriez l'applaudir parce
que c'est lui qui a fait le grenelle de
l'environnement
et voilà ça a fait flop ce n'était pas
du tout l'émotion attendue elle était
tout à fait négatifs sans doute parce
que nicolas sarkozy était en quelque
sorte trop absents alors
préciser votre pensée
est en général en général ça marche très
bien beaucoup mieux
avec des phénomènes de masse et inventif
dans l' usage de ce procédé alors
exemple exemple emmanuel macron dans son
meeting de samedi dernier à marseille où
il a évoqué brigitte macron quasiment
comme une icône comme si elle n'était
pas la même sans la nommer immédiatement
les applaudissements ont fusé c'est
alors qu'enfin qui s'est tourné vers
elle elle était en réalité physiquement
présente devant lui et puis il y à jean
luc mélenchon alors lui avec ces
hologrammes s'est lui même d'une
certaine façon qui est l'absent convoqué
magiquement présent ainsi dans la
campagne de 2010 est où il a inauguré ce
procédé est ce soir d'ailleurs il est en
meeting où il va se démultiplier avec
son hologramme programme oui absolument
y aura onze villes en effet alors qu'il
sera à lille voilà savoir au fond marqué
son absence par sa présence partout
merci beaucoup géraldine giraud merci à
vous nicolas bouzou pour un libéralisme
populaire ses positions de
l'observatoire l'air si stéphane mercier
jean rémy sa bête noire et documentaires
à demain
[Musique]